die aloysiusschule in ahrweiler
vergangenen freitag
hier sollen sich corona leutner und
rechte unter die flut helfer gemischt
haben
wir treffen den stein ergibt sich als
hausherr der schule mit corona leugnern
will er nichts zu tun haben wenn es hier
so dargestellt wird und ich habe das in
den medien ja auch mitbekommen dass sie
nur laute rechtsextreme sind oder was
auch immer
das hier sind wirklich zivile menschen
die also wo menschen für menschen da sie
den stein ein unpolitischer helfer ohne
bezug zu querdenkern auf seinem teller
gramm account ganz andere töne
kontrollieren lassen und um
unterminierung des eigentlichen
volkswillens von in diesem sinne
verbrenne ich jetzt symbolisch hier
diese masse denn stein teilt
verschwörungs videos angeblich würden
kinder sterben durch masken zwar jetzt
[Musik]
tod durch sauerstoff mann lambert die
forscht seit jahren zu verschwörungs
ideologen die gezielt hass und ängste
schüren verschwörungs ideologischem von
relativer anfang an eine zentrale
möglichkeit der mobilisierung und da
wurde immer wieder verbreitet dass
kinder angeblich an masken gestorben
werden damit es den style steht er nicht
alleine da der bekannte corona leugner
bodo schiffmann verbreitet gezielt
dieselben fake news wie den stein gibt
gehen auf die strasse eltern und lehrern
schiffmann wie gilt nicht nur auf er
will auch geld für flutopfer im aartal
gesammelt haben
wir sprechen hier von einer summe von
683 1700 und 7 euro die man aus schlägt
weil sie von querdenkern ist
vermeintliche wohltaten und ein
querdenker der sich als opfer inszeniert
wenn sie abgewiesen werden
jetzt haben mehrere spender schiffmann
angezeigt die staatsanwaltschaft
heidelberg prüft den verdacht der
veruntreuung von spenden zurück nach
ahrweiler den stein behauptet querdenker
seien hier nicht mehr aktiv wir haben
jetzt in den letzten zwei oder drei
tagen jede form von akteuren die das
ganze versuchen auf politische spielfeld
zu ziehen die versuchen
das für ihre eigenen zwecke auszunutzen
haben wir jetzt komplett raus den stein
führt uns über das schulgelände
es gibt dinge die wir nicht filmen
sollen der kameramann hat ein schild
entdeckt aufschrift veteranen pool auch
im inneren der schule immer wieder
werbung und eine spendenbox für den
veteranen pol
wir fragen steinkopf her zu dieser
gruppe gehört ich bin fan aber väter
waren ist jeder der irgendwann mal
gedient hat das ist einfach die du so
eine partie die die definition
ich bin hier weil ich habe eine
irgendeine organisation gesucht oder
eine möglichkeit wie ich hier helfen
kann der veteranen pool eine gruppe
ehemaliger soldaten die zur fluthilfe
aufgerufen haben alles ganz harmlos
sie liefern sich auch gemeinsam mit
corona leugnern kämpfe mit der polizei
wir wurden letztlich durch polizisten
grundlos attackiert und im anschluss
regelrecht gejagt und aufgegriffen
im internen chat gruppen im umfeld des
veteranen puls gibt es radikale töne
all ihr dir überall euren widerstand
leistet merkt euch unbedingt 1 das
system muss weg
hört auf euer leben von illegalen
sogenannten amtsträgern bestimmen zu
lassen so dass man eben ja ehemalige
mitglieder von sicherheitsbehörden
bundeswehr et cetera da hatte aber auch
ganz klar reichs bürger rechtsextreme
während eines hubschraubereinsatzes in
ahrweiler kommen schwarz gekleidete
männer aus der schule
einer trägt sein rechtsextremes
bekenntnis auf der haut ein totenkopf
mit wehrmacht zellen der text einer
neonazi band auf dem arm der mann
scheuchte uns von der straße spielt den
ordnungshütern kurz darauf ein
polizeieinsatz in zivil die
aloysiusschule die einsatzzentrale muss
geräumt werden
im veteranin chat ist jetzt von einem
neuen basiscamp die rede
die aden bach hütte in den weinbergen
wir fahren hin
vor der hütte stoppt uns ein posten wir
wollten mal gucken was sie machen
wir drehen heimlich die kameraden vom
veteranen pool haben sich in der hütte
eingerichtet die der stadt gehört doch
die polizei will sie auch hier nicht
dulden
am montag ist der spuk vorbei querdenker
und veteranen sind verschwunden
während andere ohne hintergedanken
anpackten und im hochwassergebiet halfen
nutzten die querdenker die note als
nährboden für propaganda